this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and this
week he's taking another look at the
weapons from the 2023 remake of Resident
Evil 4 including the iconic Chicago
sweeper and of course its legendary
infinite ammo reload uh the Thompson I
remember this quite distinctly from the
original version now this one's much
improved I think but we still got and I
remember it I remember that it was a
Reload animation complete with a little
Spin and a tip of the Hat
God damn
make sure to subscribe and check out our
other video on The Guns of the remake of
Resident Evil 4 and let us know what
other games or guns you'd like to see
each other to break down in the comments
section below right let's take a look at
more of the weapons from the remake of
Resident Evil 4.
[Music]
I thought this must be a new pistol in
the remake of Resident Evil 4 because
the Springfield XD when the original re4
came out was not super new but very new
to the American Market under that
Springfield XD name for those of you
don't know um designer made by a
Croatian company called HS product and
we don't have an XD but we do have an
xdn
different in a lot of details to the the
guy on screen anyway so not massively
helpful to show you but we do we have
managed to get an example of this very
important modern series of handguns for
the collection uh for sort of reference
and for posterity that's what it's
supposed to look like here's the M model
it's a compact pistol so it's smaller
than what's shown on screen having
cross-referenced with some imagery
though the re4 Remake version is looking
pretty good it's got all of the right
design features a couple of minor
differences I think the finger grooves
on the front are probably taken from the
Gen 3 block for example and a couple of
cuts and other features a slightly
different shapes but it's so close for a
game of this nature that's not Milson by
any means I think we can let them off
for that
all right another pistol I think it's
probably meant to be a Sig P226 X5 or
maybe an X6 as with most of the the
Resident Evil guns it's not kind of well
it's High Fidelity Graphics wise but
it's not kind of slavishly correct to
the gun close enough uh this one's got a
really weird looking well sort of way
we're looking for a pistol anyway bird
cage flash hider type although I think
it might have a breaching style
granulated
um fronts on it as well and extended
magazine and an interesting little
Medallion I didn't quite catch the
significance of otherwise it's a pistol
you know what are you gonna do I do like
the the way this game treats the the
over-the-shoulder view
um as far as the weapons are concerned
because it sort of showcases them as
they're being held and you get almost
get a sort of Zoom effect and you can
sort of admire them which is nice the
third person in third person games the
weapons are often pretty hard to see
especially if they're forever in sort of
a low ready and then in the aim as much
as they're not trying to make these
things incredibly faithful they're
really they're good bits of video game
art and you can get a really good view
of them as well
foreign
87 shotgun you've seen this very one
from our collection on this series
before it's relatively short barreled
but it does still have the butt stock
and it's not as short as the version in
the game which has done a a good job I
think the one thing that stuck out for
me that I have never seen before and I
suspect is entirely made up is the way
they've modified the lever
with these big curved flanges that
appear to be part of the lever which you
could put on there I suppose if you
wanted to and then when it's closed they
are covering a lot of the grip so as you
grip the gun your hand is around those
big flanges now I think that would be
actually be problematic for for
operating the gun they probably still
work but if they're not adding anything
now the way you would want to modify
this gun to do the the John Wayne slash
Arnold Schwarzenegger blip cocking that
we love so much and is in the game and
looks awesome the way you'd want to
modify it is by enlarging the loop quite
significantly so that when it spins
around your knuckles it doesn't snap
your fingers so I don't really know why
they've gone for that other than maybe
just to look a bit different I think it
slightly ruins the look of the gun
you've already lost a lot of the wood so
to cover up some more of the wood not a
huge fan of that design decision but
otherwise it's a very cool gun as you
can see if you did cut this thing down
and then you blanked off the end of the
the magazine tube unless you move this
bracket here down the barrel which is
probably what you'd want to do to be
fair
um you would end up with the two the
tube the magazine tube sort of floating
in space and it's it's securely attached
to the receiver so it would probably
work but I would prefer to see the
support at the front there
be a break
right Benelli M4
we've seen shown this one before I
believe it's relatively new to the
collection still the distinctive butt
stock is represented in the game um I
don't think it factors into Gameplay at
all but press button turn slide that's a
bit unusual it also got the picatinny
rail clamped to the sort of screw to the
top and it's rather more pronounced
sites which are certainly standard now
game version has much more traditional
minimalist shotgun sights on it so that
might reflect the these 20 years ago era
of the game I'm not sure but it's it's a
pretty pretty damn faithful
representation I mean compared compared
to a classic Doom 2 super shotgun with
its insano spread from short barrels
this this is a relatively realistically
tight shotgun pattern but for a game I
mean the it's it's shown to be to be
absolutely devastating and relatively
speaking but absolutely is out of a
shotgun might be a little bit Ott but
then so a sort of zombies
foreign
to start off with this here's a bit of
um tedious behind the scenes information
from here at the Royal armories so I'm
keeper as you know firearms and
artillery my counterpart Henry hello
Henry looks after Ash weapons and armor
and Asian and African collections as
well now for the most part Bose are in
his inside of the house and crossbows
fall under me so I'm supposed to know
about this stuff and now this is an
amalgam of first of all the the long
tail on the rear that you that he's that
Leon is Levering down on to [__] this
thing is absolutely a design feature of
modern crossbows pistol crossbows where
rather than use some sort of a cranakin
or a windlass or or even just if it's um
got cams on it just just pulling it back
with your fingers
um you break it almost like an air gun
and it ratchets back the these um the
boat string that's a design feature
you'd recognize if you had a modern
pistol crossbow which this is doesn't
have a butt stop the other thing that
comes to mind apart from our two rare
OSS crossbows one of which has
incendiary bolts which is a little bit
adjacent so what we see here anyway the
other main one is our Chinese repeating
crossbow which is a box Hopper that sits
on top and a stack of bolts or quarrels
and they drop onto the sort of feed tray
or the shooting tray as it were so we
have a number of things in this
collection that come to mind when I look
at this thing but it's completely
fictional in itself you could build it
you could absolutely build it but its
power level would be low it doesn't have
cams or clever systems to give you easy
spanning but high power it would be
really quite weak having said that the
way the bolts stick into the enemies
they don't go very far in so maybe it's
plausible what of course isn't that
plausible of exploding bolts I'm sure
someone could design those as well but
they'd be really quite dangerous any
kind of misfire and you've got an
explosive in front of you but I always
enjoy seeing crossbows and bows and
games to balance out give you something
a bit different than than the boring old
Firearms you know who's interested in
those
right this is so this guy looks like uh
I don't know uh Ezio after a really bad
night uh he's got a crossbow type weapon
on his on a bracer albeit it's not on
the underside concealed it's I guess
it's so overt it's covert uh not really
a crossbow either because it seems to
have two sort of flywheels like a like
the later Nerf guns they operate by by
flinging the the foam darts between two
flywheels wheels that spin very quickly
and through friction they fling the
projectile forward obviously that's very
different to a crossbow which is using
stored spring tension and then releasing
it and using a string to propel a
projectile and the magazine there's
clearly a magazine built into it with I
mean it can't be gravity fed like the
Chinese repeating crossbow of History
well it could be I suppose it could be
gravity for that
um but it's just as plausible as a
spring inside it and then hanging off
um I think I can see in the concept art
I can see what looks to be a bicycle or
brake cable so I'm not sure what that
does
enjoyable
okay the state of TMP uh tactical
machine pistol the one I've chosen today
is standard the sort of 90s early 2000s
variant like we see in the footage
however
this is very cool this is a specific
TMP holster that's March 30 MP 1993.
this is not the normal holster let me
just demonstrate how this works so this
would be sitting under my coat wraps
around your shoulders like a normal
shoulder holster I'm not going to do
that what I am going to show you though
is how this very in a very very cool
fashion
breaks out of the holster and you're
ready to punch it out and start shooting
with it quite an unusual bit of kit that
we have there the gun itself is I think
quite well well represented um Leon's
firing went before the shoulder stock
appears he's firing it down at the hip
which is absolutely legitimate that's
how it was done for decades and it's a
it's a good job so um I might point at
polymer Furniture so it doesn't look
quite right on some guns but I think it
looks absolutely spot on on a lot of
them as well so this this is nicely done
in the game absolutely recognizably a
TMP proper TMP not the spp it has this
built-in foregrip on it absolutely
essential for controlling it from the
hip as we saw it used there stocks you
can get for this we've got one that's a
side folder um the one that's attached
in the game I don't think is real but I
could be wrong usual trade-off makes the
whole gun longer more bulky but it does
make it far more stable and you can see
that reflected in the gameplay footage
as well we see the the hand to hand
magazine changes and this big old Barrel
sleeve that's quite indicative of the uh
the tmnp it's maybe a little bit narrow
probably one of the few details that
doesn't look quite right to me and
that's threaded for a suppressor
foreign
Springfield in 1903 03 A4 is the closest
real variant to this
um Iron Sights removed receiver
re-machined effectively to take scope
mounts the initial uh sort of gun viewer
shot that I'm seeing has a slightly
horrific Picatinny mounts I'm not sure
how that's supposed to be attached
obviously you can do that we have a
number four Enfield from recovered from
Iraq desert colored and it has a picked
any rail badly welded onto the top of it
so it's certainly possible not
recommended please don't do it to your
beautiful old Springfield so something
very wrong about uh the ACOG on the
Springfield that the the height of the
optic above the homeless stock is
especially weird of course it would work
but yeah this is the the real wartime
version or one of them anyway the
trigger guard Minor Details here but
this is a piece of sheet metal that's
formed into shape and uh welded onto the
um
onto the gun there the one in the game
is this slightly weird looking comes to
a weird point at the front almost like a
I don't know Beretta Trevor guard or
something on a pistol that would serve
no purpose on a rifle and in fact it
would snag on stuff as you move around
so an odd little design tweak there but
overall it's recognizably um a
Springfield 1903.
so an in placed weapon a turret weapon
sometimes disappointing
um I find in in games in different ways
this one looks pretty good appears to be
modeled after the German mg08 ground
Mount machine gun albeit it's on some
sort of mounts that I don't recognize it
is probably made up so two things I
noticed about this one is the rate of
fire is pretty high the uh all Maximum
guns chug along at about 500-ish rounds
per minute bit slower than this I would
say it's quite a good impression I think
the Spade grips are maybe a bit massive
on it so rectifier is maybe closer to an
aircraft variant or something that would
look a bit different and in case
anyone's wondering the I'm sure you're
not but let's pretend that you are
there's a very thin Round Disc behind
the the cone flash hider on the front of
the gun that is actually to hide the
flash that comes out of the muzzle
device behind that disc so as if you're
being shot at by an mg08 the cone flash
hider you know we creatively understand
how those work they literally hide the
the brightest bit of The Flash and then
the disc actually hides The Flash that's
taking place behind the cone because of
the way the Gun Works recoil operation
it's got additional muzzle flash and so
that weird looking flange that almost
looks like I don't know a ray gun a
feature of a ray gun or something that's
on the real guns and it's not not armor
it's far too thin to be armor very minor
historical detail that they have
reproduced in the game probably without
understanding what it's for and what I
should say but yeah in case you want
this
God
the Thompson I remember this quite
distinctly from the original version and
it was not the most faithful version of
the Thompson submachine gun that's ever
been put two bits and bytes I suppose
zeros and ones now this one's much
improved I think first of all we've got
open bolt operation where the bolt
starts at the rear you pull the trigger
it flies forward and gets blown back
that's nice to see it's nice to see the
bolt operating at all frankly
proportions wise it all looks good it
looks good in in use as well the side
view in detail yeah there's a lot of
fudging going on it's still a hybrid of
well take your pick really but probably
the 1928 28a1 with the ability to take
drum magazines and in basically every
other aspect it's the M1 or the M1A1 you
can't tell the difference unless you
take it apart rate of fire is too low I
think it's probably faithful to the
first game but not really faithful to
reality even the M1 is at about 900
rounds per minute so still a significant
rate of fire of course we've got here
little infinity symbol so this one is is
operating on Infinity bullets but we
still got and I remember I remember that
it was a Reload animation in the
original game I'm guessing it still is
in this as well complete with a little
Spin and a tip of the Hat tip of the
Fedora in fact so it's pretty amusing I
guess you can scale the realism of the
game somewhat by using silly outfits and
uh optional upgrades and stuff and stuff
that make the not only the gun but the
character behave differently
God damn
that was almost a pancake all right guys
you asked for it you got it more guns
from the Resident Evil 4 remake please
do check out what we do here at the
Royal armories Museum I have an article
coming out in a journal that I also I'm
on the editorial board for are Max the
Journal of the Cody Firearms Museum so
feel free to check out that site as well
you should be able to find that no
problem at all regardless of all that we
will see you again next time